hello there reject nation on Greg Alba
oh man I'm John Humphrey room yep we did
it we did the obligatory changes
supposed to say in a Scooby Doo
Trinities Mystery Machine so I have
never seen any scooby-doo things once in
my life
only like memes commercials little
snippets Clips sure you have seen a lot
of scooby-doo John Seddon Grove with
cable and scooby-doo was only on cable
apparently sorry I am a child privilege
and I'm gonna rub it in your face right
now I'm glad you finally admit it yep
and this will somehow play in tune to
the nostalgia because that's what we do
with all these trailers nostalgia I
don't buy it which I will feel plenty
I am the demographic that needs to be
the new audience to be hooked in even
though I'm not familiar with the source
material Oh
[Music]
discover the ethnic origin story the
greatest team of heroes
[Music]
[Music]
Venice Beach this mangy stray coming
with me strength
okay then what's his name his name's
solo so different this imagine dragons
[Music]
[Music]
okay Shaggy and Scooby were taken just
like you Scooby and Shaggy trace amounts
of moustache oil twelve-year-old scotch
yeah a thousand yeah a say John please
let me go first I feel like my opinion
would be the most important to this case
yeah it looks cute John please good
hahaha it does look cute I teetered back
and forth a lot in this trailer because
I don't dislike the angle I liked at
first was kind of taken aback by the
whole we're gonna do an origin story cuz
that's very popular and we're gonna make
this more comic book II cuz that's very
popular but uh yeah I mean the idea of
scene where Scooby and Shaggy first met
seemed cute the whole here's how he got
his name kind of aggravated me a little
bit and that's sort of the flavor Traci
messing with the mythology I don't care
about work this way we do I didn't need
to know that his name would came from a
random box you know like it's fine
it's just the type of thing I've seen a
thousand times before you said solo
during the trailer before you say I know
scooby snax for a thing and hey maybe he
was named after them maybe they were
named after him but it's the execution
this trailer kept endearing me with
things where I'm like oh yeah this
probably would be fun and probably there
will be better jokes than the jokes that
are here because there's also this meta
tone of voice that is very pervasive now
that just feels kind of force like that
whole thing where he's like maybe don't
ever do that again after shaggy licks
his face things like that are what makes
me worried about what we just saw but it
does look cute and the stuff where
they're all
definitely reminded me of scooby-doo but
with ya a bigger broader more
fantastical Sheen which I'm not opposed
to I mean the part of the point of
scooby-doo is that the villains were
always very down-to-earth and they had
usually some kind of way of explaining
how an apparition appeared or whatever
this looks like they're committing to go
and full-on their supernatural stuff in
this world which is I'm fine with that
generally and there are other scooby-doo
movies that have done that that's a
little bit out there for classic
scooby-doo but yeah I don't know I just
kind of hope that the overall movie
demonstrates a certain amount of heart
and a certain meta voice that isn't just
lurid and you know production notes
inspired I guess yeah sounds like you're
worried they're gonna mess with the
scooby-doo legacy no we've done
scooby-doo a thousand million times I
just it sure upset about things and
you're worried or concerned about I know
children's well yeah and I mean I get it
it's it's it's aimed directly probably
toward you know the youth of today and I
get that a year old male get that sense
from this trailer very clearly I can
feel the math well they want a new
audience I know they do and they want a
rack in a new crowd people like me late
twenties ethnic that's why there is why
they kind of Gina Rodriguez is no liar
yeah it worked man totally I was like
wow the fact that they changed female
characters names names Thelma Louise no
there's still Velma and uh you know
Daphne and Fred and that's her name
tagging
I know Shaggy and Scooby Shaggy and
Scooby well the other thing too is that
scooby-doo is always talked but he talks
full-on in this trail now my scooby
again i don't care so much but it's
saying that i don't have to be shy let
out your anger and emotion yeah that's
right not my scoops I I will have to get
used to that I think and hey if the
movie handles about cool but part of the
charm i thought of material couldn't
speak complete sentences so like it's
just that's a new thing but that is a
total nitpick just something I noticed
it can go either way I don't think it's
EPIK I think it is contradicting
everything with ya know it's really
messing with my childhood nothing is
sacred and I'm gonna go really hardcore
on my petition and get this movie remade
yeah remade with only the clout in fact
take out all the animation and just
stitch together like five episodes of
the classic cartoon and that's all I
want
petition John cut look John I know I've
been talking this whole video so I think
I should let you speak but I think I'm
gonna get one more opinion in oh no I
can't have that all right so I do really
like the origin element though when I
said origin I was like oh is this about
me dating forming and we're gonna like
flash their names on screen and I
thought that it was kind of a unique
heartfelt touch I was i watch this whole
movie of just shaggy bonding with his
puppy I was really into that side of
things
I want them to live in that part of the
world and gradually get to meeting the
other characters and whatever I don't
want this movie to rush to get there and
I think the animation feels very lively
and I I do get that complaint when they
take these IPS and they put this like
flashy modern-day animation all over it
it seems like Adams family is doing well
with audiences and box office while I
wasn't the best critic score wise but I
kind of had the same response to that
when I saw the trailer it wasn't like
the like the lego movie doesn't know
whoa that looks different and this is
kind of sort of you know yeah then again
Warner Birds did lego movie and that is
a great animated movie that's true this
this is interesting to me because it
looks like two movies stitched together
because the young stuff looks very much
like a heartwarming family animated
movie and then the adult stuff looks
like a wacky you know sci-fi horror
adventure so I also wonder if this is
gonna be like Rob Zombie's Halloween or
something where we spend the first half
hour as kids and then we cut to you know
later on in life or something to draw a
weird comparison or if we're gonna cut
back and forth frequently or what those
elements are because this trailer
suggested to me that those are going to
be two distinct parts of this movie so
that can have an interesting narrative
thrust in the way that they organize all
that I feel like that could be a cool
thing about this I'm definitely not a
Poe
to seeing an origin story I just want it
to be genuine John I think you got to
read more into it
think I know where's the subtext man
think you really gotta analyze it
where's the diversity you know this
story theme about a young white guy with
his talking puppy and his friends your
mo del Toro should have made an I think
that you know it warrants a
two-and-a-half-hour Chris yeah Gaspar
know a you know deconstruction all right
guys what are you excited for Rob
Zombie's Halloween meets scooby-doo
comment below you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
belt I like to end this with a page for
the day shout out to a man named Scuba
Steve John shout him out and your best
Scooby Doo voice read you never had to
do this before run roars beef uh you
heard of this patron nerve had this is
so hard man don't look at me making me
look at the count I'm trying
scuba hey man you know Scoob a Steve you
know you were we look forward to
shouting you out every month man and I
know we missed you once so I'm just
gonna make sure that every month we
shout you out two three four times so it
never happens again
and if there's anyone out there who can
solve the mysteries of this world it's
you my friend oh yeah